I believe this is the future of media.
To date, most media and social-change strategies
have attempted to appeal to mass audiences,
but the future is media customized for each person.
As real-time measurement of media consumption
and automated media production becomes the norm,
we will soon be consuming media tailored directly to our cravings
using a blend of psychographics, biometrics and AI.
It's like personalized medicine based on our DNA.
I call it "biomedia."
I am currently testing the Limbic Lab in a pilot study
with the Norman Lear Center,
which looks at the top 50 episodic television shows.
But I am grappling with an ethical dilemma.
If I design a tool that can be turned into a weapon,
should I build it?
By open-sourcing the lab to encourage access and inclusivity,
I also run the risk of enabling powerful governments
and profit-driven companies to appropriate the platform
for fake news, marketing or other forms of mass persuasion.
For me, therefore, it is critical to make my research
as transparent to lay audiences as GMO labels.
However, this is not enough.
As creative technologists,
we have a responsibility
not only to reflect upon how present technology shapes our cultural values
and social behavior,
but also to actively challenge the trajectory of future technology.
It is my hope that we make an ethical commitment
to harvesting the body's intelligence
for the creation of authentic and just stories
that transform media and technology
from harmful weapons into narrative medicine.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)